euromaxx highlights and here's your host
Louise Houghton hello and a warm welcome
to this edition of euromaxx highlights
now it's bog of make you squeamish you
might want to steel yourself for our
first report today here's a glimpse of
what's coming up questionable taste a
gourmet chef serve up edible insects pen
and ink why Paris Fashion can't get
enough of one man calligraphy and night
vision a film festival in finland that
doesn't sleep so what i have here in
front of me is a gourmet box of
chocolates but if you looked carefully
you'd have seen that there's something
slightly unusual on the top of them
insects now although these crunchy
creatures are eaten on other continents
around the world we're not used to
seeing them on our plates here in europe
as you can see though they are being
made into a delicacy and now one
michelin-starred restaurant has picked
up on this high protein sustainable
source of food
a visit to the michelin-starred
restaurant Aphrodite in the South of
France promises a high quality culinary
experience
but the first course is quick to turn up
a surprise meal worms and crickets are
all part of the alternative menu which
these guests have willingly ordered
northam or it doesn't put me off we
should be open to you come on may have
that on this when i first heard of it I
thought hmm you just can't stomach that
but then I thought what the heck I'll
try it the restaurant Denise with a
taste for creepy crawlies belongs to
French chef David for the 42 year old is
known for his experimental streak his
main passion is molecular cooking but
three years ago on the search for new
flavor combinations he discovered the
world of insects Zhang super wedgie
sausalito James I was traveling abroad
where insects depending on the continent
in the region I everyday ingredients in
cooking when he saline eagles are
sexless and some larger ones are even
considered delicacies showing off when I
came back to France I felt it was time
to risk something new that's what our
guests expect to valpo Nikki off the
five course alternative menu will set
you back fifty nine euros David foul
uses complementary flavors to unlock the
nutty aroma of mealworms and popcorn
like crickets
joy Pete why diesel sanctity I could
have tried to hide the flavor of the
insects with other ingredients but I
like to do things differently the worm
featured in the apple moose should be a
tasty treat for me it's important that
each dish tell a story I might shop
people with that sometimes but the
provocation is meant in a nice way salar
de pau gasol rocky edible insects are
commonplace in many regions around the
world but in europe bugs on the menu are
a no-go it's a risk this top chef is
willing to take the elderly 12 bullets
ideas will I lose the star because of
the insects will find out in 2014 when
the new Michelin Guide comes out but i
think the guide recognizes all cuisines
even those with insects and not flippant
about this ingredient and i think chefs
can prepare anything as long as it's
edible you'd was of upton Chloe the
company micronutrient meet this possible
44 based in toulouse they make all sorts
of tasty morsels using insects
exclusively in their dried form were
sold over the internet for between 12
euros and fifty euros per portion and
they also offer handcrafted pralines and
macaroons safely coil founded the
company in 2011 there's a monkey too
finicky I wanted to set up a company
that was sustainable environmentally and
also socially I really the UN
recommended the consumption of edible
insects but that in Europe there weren't
any companies that could supply such
things I simply got to it and embraced
the adventure don't ansa Donna said I
want you but first the 30 year old had
to research how to farm edible insects
with the help of a team of biologists
and agricultural economists his
experiments now also include African and
Asian insects
for now European crickets make up most
of the production seven crickets are
supposed to contain as much protein as
100 grams of steak micro nutria Saul so
has mealworms on offer this year the
company is planning to produce a ton of
these insects mmm squeal on confession
we develop products using powdered
insects our goal is to produce that
consumers are already familiar with
cannot easily did you do consume it
eating a whole in fact the way David
feau prepares it takes a bit more effort
for some guests liguria question the
taste is subtle it's very crunchy I like
that and it goes well with the other
ingredients farmers intention isn't
merely to provoke his guests he wants to
change the general attitude towards food
Oh kabali future don't we're preparing
to the future you know in a few decades
will probably have to accept that while
we may not need to eat insects
exclusively we will have to integrate
them into our meals if we should start
preparing Europeans for that now do you
ignore for now though it's early days
and a michelin-starred insect menu may
still only be possible for the most
adventurous of gourmets
and if you would like to give us your
opinion on the pros and cons of
incorporating edible insects into a
daily diet then join our discussion on
our Facebook page now if eating insects
is not your thing maybe you'd rather
wear something that looks like one for
example in the form of shoes Israeli
designer Kobe levy specializes in
abstract and eccentric designs he's
gained a celebrity following and now a
dutch museum has devoted an exhibition
to his wild and wacky creations they're
made to be worn but with names like
shark chewing gum and banana these shoes
are veritable works of art take these
pumps posing as swimming pools complete
with ladders or stilettos in the guise
of a flamingo Kobe lady has a weakness
for whimsical footwear a solo show at
the Dutch leather and shoe museum in the
city of Arabic pays tribute to the
Israeli designers eclectic work for me
is just showing what I see I'm not um
it's about combining the shoes and the
images together so you find a common
ground between the shapes because I
disregard what the shapes are this is a
shoe I okay I don't need to think about
using this one started just from looking
at at the cat stretching in the morning
stretch thanks forward and just seeing
that shoe silhouette with in that
picture Libby calls it footwear art a
pair can cost up to 2,400 euros and they
may not look like it but these shoes are
made for walking everybody recognized
the the objects that he uses and they
say look at that that's a flamingo or
that's whatever and that's the
difference between ordinary ordinary
shoes or everyday shoes and the designs
that go remix
lady isn't just striving for original
design high quality craftsmanship is a
key feature of his work he works like an
old-fashioned shoemaker without the help
of the computer his studio looks much
like the workshop recreated at the Dutch
Shoe Museum all the machines that you
see is used from hundreds of years and
they didn't change for head may choose
even though the modern techniques of
high-tech shoes casting plastic stuff
did you see the structure everything is
made in the same way it takes
fashionable guts to wear shoes like
these and ladies most famous customer
today certainly boasts those credentials
Lady Gaga ordered the model called
double boots to get an email from
someone like that famous it's very
surprising I thought a friend of mine
was fooling with me it's a practical
joke and a fake email the design can
make its way everywhere just because
what they design these shoes were
inspired by another pop diva Madonna
it's a mini character on your foot so
and i called it you know Blonde Ambition
like Madonna's to and the material is a
completely of standard so I needed to
buy like a synthetic wig and we make it
is like long fur and calm and work in
the shoe like it's like a Barbie doll
you get a lot of eye rolling in the in
the shop why do you need that wig it's
not your color honey get something else
and go explain what you're gonna do with
it but that's the fun part Livi also has
men's shoes but it's designing for women
that really fires up his imagination the
high heel gives it most cultural kind of
thing it is more three-dimensional shape
what's gonna determine if it's going to
be a high heel flat shoe a pump pattern
flip-flop or whatever it's gonna be the
theme and evidently no theme is
off-limits for kobe leaving
well these shoes may well be putting in
an appearance at Paris Fashion Week but
to get a coveted seat at the show you
will need to be in possession of an
invitation many designers send out
handwritten invites more often than not
the penmanship behind these luxurious
letters is that a French calligrapher
Nicola or schnee we met up with him in
Paris to find out more about his
creative flourish other people spend all
day banging away at a computer keyboard
but this man writes by head Nicola is
beautifully crafted handwriting as made
him one of France's most successful
calligraphers even though he's actually
a business studies graduate with no
training in graphics maybe they didn't
catch it huh I have always had good
handwriting like my father my
grandfather and my great-grandfather hey
Eddie you could say it runs in the
family divided Havana laughing Nicola
has turned his hobby into a profession
and he has an impressive list of
customers he writes invitations for some
of the most well-known luxury brands
choosing styles to match the occasion
sometimes it's romantic other times it's
modern he's also created and refashioned
logo designs for big-name companies
including French Vogue and the legendary
Hollywood hotel chateau Malmo for that
getting up see the in principle you can
turn anything into calligraphy it adds a
personal note people feel that they're
being addressed directly and that moves
them the idea that computers can replace
calligraphy is nonsense in fact it's
just the opposite the more we enter the
age of high-tech the greater the demand
for calligraphy a customer has come
calling Cecile tanya is getting married
in a few weeks
she's hired Nicola to write her wedding
invitations no way a measure would be
fair we amazing I mean of course I could
send an email but an email isn't the
same as a letter that you find in your
mailbox and keep on your bedside table
something not from a person whose dear
to you a letter written on paper with
ink it takes us back to the time of
Marie Antoinette and that appeals to me
legalized testing calligraphy styles for
different invitations this one is for an
exclusive soiree feiteng the makeup
collaboration between lancome and lava
designer Alber Elbaz by the vet report
that this style should be a little
theatrical the pattern on the invitation
reminds me of the stage I don't know if
I should use ink for it or not I can get
a more modern effect with a felt tip pen
and this is for lava for a party during
Fashion Week we'll see about
the calligrapher finds the tools he
needs in san ramon to play we've read
all opened an elegant boutique for
writing instruments here a few months
ago there are different colored inks
inkwells made of crystal and elegant
fountain pens nicola helped design the
products davek if you have a choice
between a ballpoint pen and a good
fountain pen i think you should always
take the good fountain pen beaucoup
bucks off it that forces you to make
more of an effort and think more about
the words you're going to use did you
fare Yannick especially because ink
lasts forever of it does everyone passed
off at long last the work is revealing
Nicola doesn't just know where the stars
live he gets intimate insights into the
world of the rich and famous if they
noticed all cuz all there are names that
I have to write all the time I notice
when people move when someone has a new
partner when they get divorced when they
died because they suddenly disappear or
when they simply don't get any more
invitations for when they swap places
that the fashion shows how close they're
seated to the front row is an indication
of their current status nearly saw a lot
I
Nicola oh she loves his work even if
he's facing a few sleepless nights the
Paris men's and boot couture shows are
just around the corner and thousands of
invitations have to be sent all at once
and they wouldn't be the same without
his penmanship well I think ours must
have got lost in the post so we'll move
swiftly on to the Midnight Sun film
festival that was held last weekend in
Lapland now because Lapland is located
so far north in Finland the Sun never
sets at this time of year the five-day
festival attracted over 27,000 visitors
this time including our reporter who
proved it's easier to be a night owl
when it never gets dark Saddam cooler in
northern Finland is home to 8,000 people
and a sizable reindeer population an
unlikely location perhaps for an
increasingly high-profile international
film event the Midnight Sun film
festival Romanian director christian man
Joe is in town every one of his movies
has won him an invitation to can and in
2007 he won the palme d'or just three
weeks ago manju was a member of the
canned jury it's a lot about
professionals it's a lot about the
industry it's about the big industry
while here you get back to the
spectators it will just stop you and
talk to you yesterday somebody stop me
saying look I don't like too many films
I've seen your feeling I liked it and
what do you think about this as well
thank you that's really great just
wanted you to notice good thank you
you'll look in vain here for a red
carpet or golden trophies and only a
handful of journalists make it up to the
cold climes of the Arctic Circle but
there's football calor and no shortage
of beer or you can always just dance the
night away to local music and in June
those nights literally never end
I'm traveling too many festivals all
over the cuts all over the world and
this is first of all a very friendly
festival second apart from the
mosquitoes now they are trying to eat us
alive there is a huge audience they are
very interested in the film's a no
frills no pretense celebration of cinema
was precisely the idea behind the
festival's creation back in 1986
co-founder a [ __ ] orders maki himself an
acclaimed movie director never takes no
for an answer when he invites colleagues
up here to Lapland i bet the hockey
coach mickey in thessaloniki he was
having his lifetime recognition and I
was having mine for the balkans so we
met there and he asked me he told me
look but before saying hello he said
look I I want you to promise me
something and then we'll speak I said
okay what it what is it about and said
you need to come to midnights pin son
film festival
the list of past guests reads like a
who's who of modern cinema Jim Jarmusch
Milosh Foreman Francis Ford Coppola
Fatiha keen than a delay in glory piroca
we get young and curious people not some
cultural upper-class our audience might
not be so knowledgeable but they have
hearts of gold and that's what appeals
to international filmmakers people like
Michael Powell and Samuel fuller have
said it feels here like they're seeing
their films for the first time one ng
imagine get it I'm done there's plenty
of demand for tickets whether for art
house Hollywood movies or silent era
classics the festival program also
includes an unconventional crowd pleaser
audience sing-along sessions featuring
films with a strong musical element
it's often an all-night affair thanks to
the round-the-clock summer sunshine when
you come out of a movie but it could be
3 p.m. or 3am doesn't matter either way
it's still light and that really just
changes your perception of of the day
and how we usually watch and consume
movies what I saw some time after a few
days of the festival you develop a new
rhythm you take an hour's nap and then
you go back to watching movies this is
like crazy like if you like I don't know
if you like it sleep for a moment here
and then you wake up you'll have no idea
what Tennessee winter is for sleeping as
the fence a in this part of the world
the Sun doesn't go down at all for a
stretch of 74 days and nights in the
summer heading out of the theater exit
at 1am to a sun-splashed party on the
shore a quite unique cinematic
experience now to finish the show today
we take a look at how Buddhism is
increasingly influencing one aspect of
living in the Western world namely the
home environment there are more more
people in Europe who see the Buddha
statue as a symbol of spirituality peace
and tranquility and they're turning to
this figure as a reminder to find some
moments of peace in their busy lives
the Buddha is a religious symbol revered
by millions around the world in recent
years the figure has gained popularity
in the west where people see it as a
meaningful way to establish an
atmosphere of harmony in their homes and
gardens The Mikado a sciatica gallery in
Berlin specializes in exclusive models a
bronze buddha imported from Thailand
costs a thousand euros this wooden
statue from my an MA costs four times
that amount oh no yoga nunca bought his
first board of 45 years ago demand for
the statues in Germany has exploded
since then the gallery in Berlin is one
of five run by Mikado se Attica few
customers are Buddhists but most of them
do for a spiritual connection thus in
China and wonders what attracts people
here to Buddhism is not the religion but
the philosophy which they equate with
harmony and relaxation that's what
people are looking for that's it was
first dimensions open
buddhist statues have also become
increasingly available in furniture
shops this berlin store are for several
models with the cheapest costing less
than 10 euros a Buddha fountain is
available for 69 from chain stores to
exclusive dealers there are many options
for anyone on the hunt for a Buddha
statue you mentioned your Haider the
people who buy these things are
searching for a sense of internal or
external harmony nah that's the best way
to put it past am besten I know would
also harm will need the demand for
statues is just one manifestation of a
growing interest in Far Eastern
spirituality in Germany an estimated
five million Germans practice some form
of yoga or meditation while the Dalai
Lama is regularly named as a role model
in surveys for many in Germany Buddha
has become a spiritual figurehead would
understand people who engage with Buddha
are looking for something it's a search
we know well and it takes place in
societies where there's little material
suffering when existential questions of
a material nature are less urgent people
start looking for deeper meanings in the
notice in to listen but Buddhism hasn't
gained substantial ground as a religion
in the West the number of Buddhists in
Germany is fairly stable at 250,000 or
about 0.3 percent of the population the
gandan Tashi gerling monastery near
Berlin is just one of five in the whole
country
the monks anuncia have registered the
fascination non-buddhists have with
buddha
vengeance they are there as if I would
hope that people draw inspiration from
it and that it has an effect on them
inside and outside I have no
reservations about people putting
Buddha's on display it would be nice if
there were more butter figures around
but if they're just for decoration then
we ask that they please be treated with
the appropriate respect Buddha statues
are also popular outdoors as your
lifestyle in Bavaria even has its own
Buddha display garden one of the
highlights is this four-ton laughing
buddha valued at fifteen thousand euros
but that's small fry compared to this
marble statue which costs a whopping 80
thousand euros thomas wylde moolah set
up the company in his garage in 2002
since then has supplied about five
thousand Buddha's to customers around
Germany it would be its animal Trenton
name with the internet and globalization
life's becoming more hectic everything
has to be faster and better Buddhism
promises peace and tranquility and let
you win down a bit listen between the
window fun when the weather is fine
German spend as much time as they can in
their gardens so it's little wonder that
Buddha's can be found in leafy
environments here Peter shabbos shares
his garden with a two metre high marble
Tibetan Buddha
a party atmosphere can guard the Buddha
changed the atmosphere in the garden in
a really good way he made it karma he
takes me away from stressful thoughts
it's meditative leave Buddhist statues
in Western climbs encouraging
contemplative indoor/outdoor living and
on that peaceful note it's time to say
goodbye for today so on behalf of all of
the euromaxx team here in Berlin thanks
for joining us and until next time take
care and goodbye
Oh